oui ce matin et à 4 à brasser les cartes
du jeu totem des cartes qui représente
80 animaux et 80 qualité que les
participants sont invités à associer
pour définir leur totem à tour de rôle
une occasion pour se dire ce qu'on
apprécie chez l'autre toujours dans un
esprit positif quand et là on se sent
jamais de ça on se sent toujours appuyé
puis on peut compter sur toi
didier en outre une mission c'est de
faire en sorte que les gens bx connect
plus sentir à quel point ils sont ils
sont importants qu'on veut que chaque
personne sache ce qu'il a fait briller
de mille feux
c'est en partant de ce principe que
j'attendais un spécialiste de la
croissance personnelle a eu l'idée en
2015 de créer un jeu pour faciliter ces
échanges positifs les premiers bouchons
plutôt rudimentaire mais il a la chance
d'avoir auprès de lui sa conjointe et sa
part a dit une graphiste qui ajoute aux
descriptions le principe de
l'utilisation des animaux qui donne une
toute autre dimension rouge mais nous
c'est symbolisme animal rapidement qui
nous a interpellé la puissance
d'utiliser les forces des animaux pour
qualifier une personne le meilleur de ce
convoi d'une personne si le principe du
totem n'est pas nouveau il est utilisé
par les scouts entre autres qu'il a
permis de définir le concept et l'image
de totem
si le jeu un certain succès public il a
surtout été rapidement remarqué par les
professionnels qui ont vu un outil
d'intervention
à la base c'est pour les familles les
amis pizza on s'est rendu compte
vraiment que et avait beaucoup d'autres
personnes qui l'utilisait comme les
thérapeutes dans les écoles dans les
entreprises plus on a fait droit aux
pieds il ya une porte est vraiment plus
grande que ce qu'on pensait une portée
qui selon les concepteurs soutient les
ventes de totem aux états unis où il est
disponible sur amazon à l'origine de la
plus grande part du chiffre d'affaires
une entente viennent également d'être
conclu avec un distributeur européen
pour les ventes dans les pays
francophones
il existe des versions italiennes et
russes en plus des versions anglaise et
française
on est en train de créer un paquet de
gains
également là qui va permettre d'aider
les gens à utiliser totem en entreprise
pour faire de consolidation d'équipé
dans la classe donc pour aider les
professeurs à développer l'estimé de soi
des jeunes créent des liens également
pour les tous qui thérapeute nouveau jeu
nouveau guide l'élu concepteurs de totem
qui vivent déjà des revenus de leur
entreprise estime être en mesure
d'atteindre le million de ventes du jeu
et de ses déclinaisons tout ça à partir
d'un désir d'aider les gens à se dire
combien il se prit ce dénis lapière
radio canada 5